Freak bitches.
So it was one of the great challenges in life is knowing enough to think you're
right,
but not enough to know you're wrong.
Uh,
yeah.
Well that is a big problem with a lot of people that watch these youtube videos.
That's what it is.
They say,
oh,
this is right.
Oh my gosh.
But they don't know enough to know why it's wrong,
but this is what I wanted to talk to you about.
Uh,
what is it about people that there's this,
this,
this very compelling need to find something out that other people don't know.
Like the world is flat,
like dinosaurs aren't real.
Like that kind of stuff is very compelling to people.
So what I do in those cases,
in the,
uh,
yeah,
so what I do is I would say instead of debating them and some of some of your
listeners are listening to this right now,
it's what all I would do is say,
what is your best single bit of evidence for what you're claiming
and what would it take to show that you're wrong?
All right,
well let's go get a simple one.
So,
so,
so that's what I would ask and I've done this exercise and it doesn't work.
You know why?
Why?
Because there was a guy who didn't believe we went to the moon.
We spent a third of our time in our last session,
goes into there.
So there's someone I know who doesn't believe he went to the moon rather than
just say he's skeptical.
So I said,
what kind of evidence would convince you?
He said images of the landing site of the Apollo missions.
So I said,
okay,
here's a website where we sent a,
if I wasn't west,
it was the Chinese.
I think Chinese or Europeans sent aced a probe to an orbiter,
to the moon.
So it was close enough because ground based telescopes are not,
don't.
They don't have the resolution to see the landing sites.
But via close enough to the moon you can the.
It photographed the entire surface of the moon.
And there were the landing sites and you saw the rover tracks and the base for
the lunar module.
And so he,
that night he went home and found it and then he came back and says,
well,
NASA could have faked that.
Well,
I'm done with you.
We have no more to talk about because he's not ready to be convinced.
Well,
that's a weird.
Because he gave him the evidence he asked for exactly that would convince him
and it did not convince them.
And the other thing that's going on here,
which is still a theory I'm working on,
but there seems to be a disturbing peek at what a matriarchy would be like.
And I'm seeing a lot of women in these movements who are sort of vindictive and
cruel.
And like this woman we're talking about,
uh,
you know,
you watch these videos and you hear like,
fuck 'em up these women's voices from behind the crowd.
And I called them shit chest.
Let's that woman from the University of Missouri.
Can I get some muscle over here?
Remember her?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She wants men to fight on her behalf.
And you know,
Ironman has that blue thing in his chest.
I don't think women are evil.
I like our women are like ironman there magic,
right,
but by ripping out that blue thing,
you're ripping up the ability to have children and be mothers and everything,
and then you put in a piece of shit into iron man's chest.
That's what feminist and like this woman are there.
Shit chests.
They're malfunctioning robots and they're like,
this kill him.
Milo wants genocide killing.
So do you think that they're imitating what they think are patriarchal
societies?
They're doing their version of it and that's what they're doing with this.
The whole matriarchal posturing.
Yeah.
It's like Clark Kent,
I want to run an article.
I'm writing.
No,
you're not running a clerk.
Simmer down,
dude.
You write your article.
I'm doing mine.
No.
Can he crunches up?
There's not a whole lot of matriarchal societies in the animal world other than
hyenas.
I try.
There's a few of them is a few where the females are larger than the males.
A few bugs especially,
but hyenas in particular,
the female hyenas are much larger than the males.
They even have fake Dick's penis.
He has this big large tube fake Dick that hangs down.
They actually give birth out of it and they climb on top of the males and they
fucked him and the speculation,
what?
There's a lot of speculation as to why the females are bigger,
but one of them is that they think that she has to be bigger because Nina's are
so god damn ruthless.
They eat their babies.
Oh.
So the female has to go get the fuck away from the booby good to when she gets
on top of books.
Um,
you piece of shit did.
It's my baby.
I mean there's no more,
you know,
no pun intended,
dog eat dog world than a fucking Hyena world.
You're out there fighting for scraps with lions.
Yeah.
Well,
I actually have described Antifa and these people as hygienists because that
thing I was talking about at Berkeley where there are guys went in and said,
I thought you guys were tough or something,
was his exact quote and they're going to get him,
get him,
fuck him up.
And then the guys sort of give up because no one wants to fight them.
They start walking away and then someone runs up behind him,
knocks him out with a flag pole as they're screaming easy Italian slogans by the
way,
like,
no,
she's thought the flashy stuff from the 19 twenties having fun.
They knock yet game.
They're larping and then knocked him out and then as soon as he's out that the
hyenas come out and then they start kicking his unconscious body and they start
grabbing.
They're really little.
It's,
yeah,
it's online.
You can find.
I have people that I talked to,
professionals,
um,
obviously like sports psychologists or sports psychologist.
And then you got to get a psychologist in general to deal with the depression,
whatever.
When you hit your lows,
like it's okay to,
to get,
you know,
if you're bench pressing 350 pounds,
it's okay to have a little touch.
It's okay to have a little spot here and there,
you know,
and then after you get a couple of spots,
now after a while you can do it yourself.
You don't need the spot anymore.
That's how I look at psychiatric help to an extent.
For some people,
especially if they're battling depression.
Sometimes you just need a floaty and you did,
and then you can take the floaties off after a year.
You
see what I'm saying?
It's a mental,
it's a mental floaty and it's okay because we all hit low part low points in our
life where it's unbearable and you either allow it to continue to be unbearable
and just deny it or you deal with the task at hand and say,
I'm a little low right now.
I need the floaties.
It's okay.
I'll get through this,
and then when you take the photos off,
you realize I only needed them for a little bit of time and now I'm okay.
I'm here,
and that's kind of what it felt like.
It's like I just needed a little bit of a push.
I needed to get through this and learn some things about my own,
my own mind and understand my own emotions and understand that I didn't need all
these things that I was thinking where it real.
It was me not being in control of my own emotions,
your own emotions or your choice and I chose to feel trapped.
I chose to be sad.
I chose to feel like I was Jack Shit.
I chose all these things and it's like you don't need fighting to be these
things.
You need to.
You need to let go of fighting to learn that you are something without it,
and that was actually a gift.
It became a gift because I learned so much in life now bigger than fighting.
I look at the things that I went through as a gift because I have gotten the
gift of feeling
retired during my career.
Who else gets that?
Some people retire for five years,
lose their freaking mind,
end up in the bar and come back and try to fight again 10 years later with a
weakened body,
a mess or abuse.
Why?
Why though?
Why are they doing that?
They're not doing it because they're physically capable.
They're doing it because they never dealt with their life away from fighting.
Fighting was there like fighting is who they are.
Fighting is their persona,
so take away fighting.
What are they?
They're in the bar drinking away with.
They're not.
Instead of drinking,
putting the booze down and knowing what you are without fighting,
being happy with that chapter of your life and being able to live who you are.
I've gotten to feel that and now I can fight with a peace of mind,
knowing how good I am without fighting and how great I am with it too.
And um,
that's,
that's what this thing's about.
All these fights,
all these me attacking those challenges coming back and winning and getting my
belt back.
Um,
that could only happen because I let go of control of the things I couldn't
control.
Okay?
But here's,
here's part of the problem when you're talking about people who troll online,
go back to when you were a young liberal and you thought that if I was a doctor
and I was making $3 million a year course,
I should be given 70 percent in taxes.
You don't have that.
So you're looking at the people who do in this part of you is like,
give it away,
man.
You shouldn't do.
You don't deserve it.
Give it away.
That same mentality exists with trolls.
They don't have anything going on.
They're fucking losers for the most part,
so what do they want to do?
They want to burn it all down.
They want the whole thing burned down.
Go trump,
go try.
The reason why they want to say go trump is because they want this clearly
maniacal person to just throw a fucking monkey wrench into the gears and watched
the whole system explode.
That's half of what they're doing.
They don't have a vested interest in it.
They're not.
They're not successful.
They're not happy.
They're not doing well.
I think their roles,
if you're talking about all trump supporters,
I think part of that is true.
I'm not talking about all.
Okay,
okay.
Because I was talking about all trump supporters.
I'm talking about trolls.
Those people with the green frog fucking with the crazy hair on their twitter
profile.
There's a lot of them that have you go over their twitter feed,
their online,
13 hours a day,
shitting on people.
I mean,
that's what some people do.
I've gone.
I looked at this,
a few people that I follow and I don't follow them either.
I just go to their page,
I have them bookmarked and I'll go to their page like,
look at this crazy asshole.
What's he been up to today and what have they been up to?
Just trolling liberals.
Just going crazy and shitting on that.
Jake tapper.
Guy Boyd is fucking guy's twitter feed is a mess.
Why?
Because he,
he fucking summoned the ire of the trolls.